so we've seen now how to fit uh
regression models with uh with uh
splines and polinomial regressions we're
going to move on now to generalize
additive models so the first part of
this um this section of the lab goes
through something similar to what we saw
for just having modeling wage as a
function of age uh we're going to to
skip that to talk about the more
interesting aspect of Gams or additive
models that is when we include more than
one feature so the first model we're
going to fit with more than one feature
uh is going to be not necessar not
strictly a gam but it's going to include
splines for the wage as a function of
age and a function of year um okay so
we'll see we're going to fit natural
splines for both of these with different
degrees of freedom and we'll you know
use ordinar Le squares regression as we
had above for the the natural spline and
B spline fits so if you if you just look
in that expression for for EXs you see
we got a nonlinear term in age we got a
nonlinear term in year and then we've
also got education which is a
categorical variable and we're going to
be fit in constants at each of the level
of those so we putting all three of
these into a model and and you'll get
these the fits for the two nonlinear
functions and this these constants yes
yeah I did not mention the the education
and uh this is just to the distinction
between what we've seen before really is
that now we have more than one feature
and that's really what makes it an added
model um so often in an additive model
you want to look at uh the individual
effects of each feature and that's
typically done through a partial
dependence plot so I'm not going to go
through the each all the the steps of
the the code to produce these partial
dependence plots but what the what I
want to show here is that for each of
the the features in the model you get a
a nonlinear function so here is an
estimated effect of the the nonlinear
effect of um age on on wage and the y-
axis here is kind of arbitrary because
there's because there are other features
in the model unlike uh when we just had
age that was you know we actually had
the raw y scale and we could see that
the the form is actually relatively
similar to what we saw before though
it's not quite as flat up here but it
has the same sort of inverted quadratic
type of fit so the the general message
here Jonathan is that with standard
linear models you get a coefficient for
each variable with additive models you
get a fitted function for each variable
and year we showing the fitted function
for age but we could we could show you
the function for year and uh and we can
show the set of conscience for education
and so it's a nice generalization of of
linear models yes
yeah so we also as Trevor just mentioned
there's there will be a fitted function
for year as a function it's effect on
wage and there will also be a oh we
haven't plotted them but there will be
estimated coefficients for each
education
level
okay um so what we had just fit there
let's get to the right spot what we just
fit there was just ordinar squares right
we had we had specified a flexible
function for each of the two features
and uh dummy variables for the the
education level uh and it wasn't
strictly what's called what wasn't
strictly a generalized additive model
because it didn't have this smoothing
penalty that we saw we see in the the
lectures for chapter 7 so here we're
going to do a similar fit uh using the
pyam function a pyam library so linear
gam from the pyam library tells us tells
pyam that we're going to do a regression
problem and pyam is not set up um to to
to consider um feature names it only
considers column indices uh in
specifying a model so this sgam zero
here says s gam stand stands for
smoother or H sorry spline for gam zero
indicates the the First Column of the
Matrix that will'll ultimately fit uh
and you'll see this xgam Matrix the
First Column of it will be age so we're
going to this is the a spline for age um
if this s gam one with number of splines
equals seven um this is this says that
uh well you use whatever number N
splines means for for year for the
second column okay I just want to in to
point out that unlike the model spec the
gam function doesn't use variable names
in in specifying it but uh it's fit
using a fit
method and we've written a function in
in the islp package to make these
partial dependence plots uh for the um
for for the fitted model so I'm just
showing you here the uh the partial
dependence plots for age on wage when we
don't specify any parameters to this the
S gam function the spline function for
gam um so this indicates we'll of course
want to tune this so lamb Lambda equal
06 is not very smooth compared to the
other one so maybe one thing we could do
is we could try and to estimate um a
Lambda that gives us a certain number of
degrees of freedom so here we're going
to try and get five degrees of freedom
for the um for the age term and five
degrees of freedom for the year term and
that corresponds to finding these lamb
values these Lambda values uh then these
are um so what we've done is we've
modified the Lambda values of our
original gam and refitt it here so now
let's look at the partial dependence
plot and the they do they are smoother
than before and so we've used roughly
five degrees of freedom for um each of
these plots each of these
effects okay so here's a plot this this
is what a partial dependence plot for
categorical variable would look like it
would be a coefficient for each
category okay so I'm just going to wrap
up here with a uh an example of how to
use binary uh regression for gam what
changes really just is the base
estimator instead of being linear gam
it's logistic gam things are specified
in the same way here one in this in this
gam uh instead of using a spline for
year I'm going to use a linear effect
for year that L stands for instead of a
smoothing spline for an effect a linear
effect okay so we fit
um uh using the same method the fit
method okay and then we can uh look at
the partial dependence plots one thing
we see um in this paral in these fits is
some rather unusual behavior um for the
estimate of people who do do not have a
high school diploma for high high wage
earners and that's well what's happening
in this case is there really are likely
no people who don't have a high school
degree who are making more than 250,000
so we can't estimate this parameter so
that causes these estimates to look very
variable so we're going to refit the
model excluding those the the the
observations that um
don't have more than a high school
diploma or n and now we see well we have
reasonable estimates of the effects of
um uh of being a high earner for the
different uh levels of
education and just like the linear Gams
we can produce partial dependence plots
for each of the the features here this
is the partial dependence plot for year
and I think we have the partial
dependence plot for for um age and
actually interestingly this one doesn't
seem to have that precipitous drop off
that we saw when we just modeled with
age oh so that's good I'm glad to see
that yes maybe it's cuz i' I've had a
good education I think
so